hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where right now we are
playing through the first uh level of
sifu without dying um i've just recorded
myself going through the gameplay um so
that you can finish at age 20 and then
start the next level at age 20 as well
so you can start the club at age 20. um
i mentioned in some youtube comments and
on twitter that i had been able to do
this after a couple of hours and
some people accuse me of lying but more
people ask for help so this is for those
people to the people who ask for help i
first want to say stop watching this
please
try and figure it out yourself i promise
that you can it took me a couple of
hours until the game really clicked for
me and i understood i got the parry
system i understood the combos that i
wanted to lean on and where um i got the
timing and i also understood for me i
have a massive focus on making sure that
i get weapons or that i know where
weapons are and i make sure that i take
them out
but that's all stuff that you can learn
by yourself um and that it's so
rewarding to figure out the systems of
this game and to figure out how it works
um
like there are more tips that i can give
you that i don't want to give you over
here
you've got this it's so rewarding and i
imagine that this first level especially
they expect you to get through without
any deaths i'm i have no doubt that um
this is something that's very achievable
for for most players who just put the
time in to kind of learn the mechanics
so promise you can do it give it a shot
however i also see no shame in needing
help or finding things hard that's like
one of my least favorite internet
discourses is
like that there's a weird shame in
people finding things hard we all find
different things hard everybody does
that's
that's being human um so definitely no
shame in it but
i think this room especially
um people have
found um to be a little bit
challenging and i think it's because
they're not going to take out the
individual enemies like i do here
um i also got a trophy the first time
that i jumped over that box
fun fact if you're trying to get a trick
you'll also get a trophy for finishing
the level um without any debts so
you'll get double that there and yeah i
always swap my weapons out for
durability purposes but um yes obviously
in this room i made sure to take people
out individually
so that uh they can't all just spread
out and grab weapons and then beat the
crap out of you with them basically um
because i think that's what makes this
room kind of extra hard in some cases
there is also um you do need to look out
for it took me so long to figure out the
certain enemies that will come back
rebuff if you do take downs on them
which in this instance is this guy right
here
um who just did the kick on me so i'm
i'm
careful about trying to avoid doing
takedowns on them because you can see
from his health bars kind of glowing um
and sometimes they'll have like smoky
shoulders so just don't do takedowns on
them
and make sure we take them out the slow
way
just to not bring them back to life
basically
um and then yeah i always go and get
this pipe over in this corner
uh another thing that i want to mention
is
when i first played the game i had a lot
of trouble because i have tendonitis in
both my wrists which is
an accessibility issue
in video games
i can't play any game or at least i'm
always very bad at any game that
requires any rapid button tapping
because it's extremely painful my wrist
gets small i have to put ice on them um
it really really sucks
so oh that's everybody in the level dead
by the way not some old debt
except for the um main boss that's how
fast it is it's like five minutes it's
not um but thankfully the team at
slo-clap actually did include the
ability to um
remap buttons that's such a huge win for
me i'm so glad that they did that so
that i can play through the game without
pain and uh you know when you're in pain
you're like fighting against your own
body more so than you're fighting
against the controls um but i did
actually play through this
uh with default controls just because i
wanted to make sure everything on screen
looked the same for anyone who's playing
at home so this is not the control
scheme that i'm used to and i do
accidentally press the wrong button like
more than once while playing through
this because i have gotten myself
used to a different control scheme
thanks to that button remapping
uh and this fight was probably the
hardest part about that i would say but
yeah i had a lot of trouble you know
playing the first hour with the regular
controls and then swapped it over and it
got way way way way easier for me so
yeah very very thankful for that
it makes such a big difference
um
he's a bit of a jerk anyway
taking that posture down and i think i
find the first part of this
fight harder than the second part but
like i said i will take hits if it means
i can pick up
the weapon i'm like hey it does it does
so much extra damage that's obviously
something that i really um
focused on also
throws wherever you can
is a huge thing like if you can throw
him into
the um
the plants
and i'm clearly on my focus meter as
well like i feel like i barely even use
it that much outside of the boss fights
because they don't really need to
whereas in the boss fights like it just
does so much damage that it's totally uh
worth
trying to pick up so i'm looking at that
most the time while playing through it
it's such a cool cinematic it's so neat
and yeah if people enjoy this video i
might try and do it for every level
because i'm really enjoying the game i
really really like it um
people want to see me try and get
through all of them without dying i'm
sure
it's only going to get harder and hotter
and hotter of course
but yeah if you guys enjoy it let me
know
and
make it happen i might stream some of it
i'm not really sure
yeah i didn't want to
play while recording just because i
figured that i wouldn't
be able to speak i'm never very good at
that
i was like let me just record
myself doing it and then i can record
the commentary afterwards and both of
those things will make more sense
so that's what i did here i don't even
remember if i did it but you can smash
him back into the
bamboo
um yeah those throws and grabs uh
helpful in a lot of fights that is also
very easily blockable but clearly
there you go
and there is also
i didn't do it this time either i don't
think maybe i am looking for it
i think i am looking for it yeah like i
said i will take hits
i don't care
oh and you can keep throwing if you
don't hit them against something
yeah i i'm intentionally moving at that
area to go back and get that extra
bamboo stick
[Music]
and there it is
preparing super fun the level becomes so
short um once you get through it that
way it's it's crazy
um i wonder how long it would take to
like actually stitch every
level of the game together if you've
gotten used to them like that but um
yeah let me know if you want to see more
of them we'll see
i love it i'm such a fan of this game
it's totally a game of the year
contender for me
thank you for watching see you next time